[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir haslem
ça fait beaucoup de monde a rencontré ce
que mon travail c'est la rencontre
j'aimerais partager avec vous un certain
nombre de réflexions sur comment
travailler sur la mécanique de la
rencontre peut permettre de construire
l'avenir
avant ça si vous le voulez bien on va
faire un petit exercice rapide à mon
signal je vous donnerai 15 secondes pour
trouver quelqu'un que vous ne connaissez
pas au rang derrière vous ou au rang
devant vous et lui poser une question
une seule question celle que vous voulez
vous avez réfléchi c'est parti
merci merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je parierais mais je peux me tromper que
la plupart d'entre vous ont choisi
comment t'appelles-tu d'où viens tu et
qu'est ce que tu fais dans la vie
j'envoie manifestement dans les premiers
rangs qui ont osé est ce que tu es seul
en ce moment et qu'est ce que tu fais
après le spectacle maintenant je vais
vous poser une question à vous même et
cette question c'est si j'avais voulu
maximiser les chances d'apprendre
quelque chose de cette personne quelle
est la question que j'aurais dû poser
on y reviendra plus tard il ya deux ans
et demi environ
j'étais au musée du louvre à paris
beaucoup d'entre vous connaissent je
suppose pour une grande visite de groupe
on était environ une trentaine venus de
tous les pays du monde
tout le monde s'était inscrit sur un
groupe facebook on y parlait de mémoire
russe espagnol arabe dari français
anglais et j'en oublie certainement
après deux heures et demie de visite
dans les salles des antiquités
orientales
on va tous dans le jardin des tuileries
pour faire connaissance salut comment tu
t'appelles qu'est ce que tu fais tu
viens d'où moi pendant la visite j'avais
remarqué un type 1 m 65 brun le visage
un peu émacié en lame de couteau un gros
sac à dos est manifestement quelqu'un de
talent et en antiquités orientales parce
qu'elle avait posé un certain nombre de
questions vraiment pertinente au guide
du tp là alors je m'approche de lui je
lui dis bonjour enchanté je m'appelle
david talent est recalé en antiquités
orientales
tu habites dans le coin tu viens souvent
hélas avec un mouvement d'épaulé à peine
perceptible il désigne son sac à dos et
une dit ça dépend des soir là je
comprends que la personne qui est en
face de moi vit dans la rue depuis des
mois qu'on est à paris
fin novembre et là tout à coup les mots
brin arabophones et cultivées sont
immédiatement remplacés par trois mots
qui m'empêche de voir toute autre chose
réfugiés syriens et sans abri trois mots
dans lesquels on trouve l'écho d'une
violence l'image de la pauvreté mais
rien qui rappelle le fabuleux moments
qu'on a passé ensemble au musée ni
l'apport intellectuel que cette personne
a eu pour le groupe
pendant la visite c'est une visite qui
était organisé par une association dont
l'objectif est précisément de faire
changer les perceptions que les citoyens
locaux ont des nouveaux arrivants
pourquoi changer les perceptions lorsque
si on se place un petit peu plus haut à
la perspective des états on arrive assez
rapidement à une impasse
traditionnellement on pense qu'il ya
deux réflexes quand on est face à un
phénomène comme le phénomène migratoire
qu'on connaît en méditerranée en europe
depuis 2015 premier réflexe un réflexe
de rejet de repli d'une manière ou d'une
autre on sent son identité menacée
donc on ferme les frontières deuxième
réflexe un réflexe qu'on pourrait
qualifier d' humanitaires devant un
drame humain évident si on a les moyens
alors on a le devoir moral de faire
quelque chose on gère l'aide alimentaire
l'hébergement l'aide juridique
éventuellement bref en gère l'urgence
mais à aucun moment on pense emprunté
une troisième voie une troisième voie
qui consisterait à ne pas considérer
l'intégralité de ce phénomène comme un
problème exclusivement dans tous
phénomènes scientifiques économiques
rien n'est toujours tout un problème il
ya forcément un enseignement à tirer
quelque chose de positif aller chercher
moi quand je réfléchis à ce qui crée de
la richesse en général d'un point de vue
scientifique intellectuel et économique
j'arrive toujours à la même réponse ce
qui crée de la richesse d'une manière ou
d'une autre c'est de l'innovation et
l'innovation c'est quoi l'innovation
c'est faire un pas de côté et regarder
la chose différemment penser
différemment agir différemment je suis
tombé un peu par hasard il ya trois
semaines
sur la définition du mot réfugier dans
la première encyclopédie ou celle qu'on
considère comme la première encyclopédie
du monde occidental celle de diderot et
d'alembert au xviiie siècle
et bien cette époque réfugiés ça
signifiait un protestant français qui
fuient la monarchie catholique pour
aller je cite apporter ses talents à
l'ennemi qu'est ce qui empêche les
personnes qu'on appelle les migrants de
révéler ce talent qu'elles sont censées
apporter et bien une chose une chose les
en empêche fondamentalement aujourd'hui
c'est la chose qui fait le point commun
de tous les citoyens locaux partout dans
le monde et leur force c'est le capital
social
c'est quoi le capital social c'est quoi
votre capital social votre famille vos
amis vos collègues vos colloque tous ces
gens qui tous les jours vous dise oui tu
as raison de penser ce que tu penses de
faire ce que tu fais est d'aller où tu
vas tous ces gens qui contribuent à
votre confiance en vous à votre projet
professionnel à votre choix d' indolore
de faire toutes les petites choses du
quotidien comment on crée du capital
social ça veut dire quoi finalement ça
veut dire comment on crée mes amis
cette question paraît très stupide à
n'importe quel étudiant en échange
linguistique à n'importe quel expatrié
envoyé par son entreprise à l'autre bout
du monde
c'est facile pour se faire des amis on
va à l'université on prend des cours on
va voir ses collègues après le travail
on va faire la fête
évidemment pour un nouvel arrivant
bizarrement la question se pose pas de
cette manière là alors un groupe de
jeunes gens à paris n'avait à l'époque
même pas la trentaine a décidé de monter
une communauté un espèce de club ouvert
à tous gratuit donc plutôt une
communauté dans laquelle attention scoop
on viendrait ne faire que ce qu'on aime
tant quand on s'inscrit dans un club de
foot c'est qu'a priori on aime le foot
donc jusque là pas très original mais le
principe de cette communauté qui est
original c'est que tout ce qu'on fait
c'est fait pour que chaque local et
plusieurs amis nouveaux arrivants et
chaque nouvel arrivant réfugiés et
plusieurs amis locaux
reconstruire les bases du capital social
futur qui fait qu'on aura peut-être
moins de problèmes par la suite
emma aujourd'hui sont des milliers dans
toute l'europe
nous sommes des dizaines de milliers
dans toute l'europe tous les samedis
matin assad va courir avec céline céline
elle fait du marketing et quand elle
crache pas ses poumons pour essayer de
rattraper assad
elle lui raconte un petit peu ce que
c'est que le marketing parce que lui il
aimerait reprendre des études dans le
marketing
tous les jeudis résa donne un cours
d'histoire du moyen-orient à david qui
n'y connaît rien mais comme il était
prof de français au moins lui corrige
son français pendant que lui-même prend
son cours tous les mardis et les
vendredis mahmoud et julien prennent
d'un côté des cours d'arabe et de
l'autre côté des cours de cuisine
française alors ils grossissent et ils
progressent tous les deux dans leur
discipline respective
depuis des années nawal soit amarrée med
ont retrouvé un logement un travail des
amis ont repris des études
céline sofia lice thomas vincent
apprennent une langue étrangère
s'épanouissent font du théâtre ont des
amis
cuisiner à prendre courir davantage
quand on fait que ce qu'on aime c'est
qu'on le fait avec beaucoup de
motivation
jusque là c'est pas franchement un scoop
non plus ça s'appelle l'épanouissement
personnel et mais ce qu'on fait faire ce
qu'on aime
mais là où ça devient intéressant c'est
quand on relit le plaisir et l'impact
social qu'on peut créer il ya trois ans
j'ai rencontré une ong
cette ong dont je vous parlais au début
au musée qui s'appelle things are je
suis venu les voir à une réunion
d'information et puis j'ai dit bonjour
je m'appelle david j'ai 36 ans je suis
marié j'ai deux enfants j'adore cuisiner
et manger de la chukka et boire du bon
vin et jouer à la pétanque
et puis j'aime aussi regarder le foot à
la télé mais je suis pas très fort je
préfère le regarder à la télé que le
jouer en vrai j'adore faire du vélo
j'aime aussi faire de la randonnée
et puis j'aime aussi aller au cinéma
pour voir des comédies et puis faire des
phrases très très longue
et puis j'aime aussi écrire et raconter
des histoires comment je pourrai vous
aider
ils me regardaient ils m'ont dit tu
continues à faire ce que tu aimes
seulement ce que tu aimes mais tu viens
de faire avec nous tu vas rencontrer des
tas de personnes que tu pensais pas
rencontré et qui vont apprendre des
choses
si vous aussi vous avez quelque chose à
partager
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]